c'est un des derniers bastions de
l'opposition au régime de bachar al
assad en syrie est depuis la semaine
dernière la gutta orientale est de
nouveau un enfer sous les bombes de
l'aviation syrienne et russe les
secouristes d'urgence disent ne plus
suffire à la tâche
des scènes similaires se déroulent dans
la province d'idlib
alors qu'à a filmé ce sont les turcs qui
sont à l'offensive
la situation est plus inquiétante et
dangereuse que jamais a dit l'envoyé
spécial des nations unies au conseil de
sécurité civile been killed en afrique
scale les civils ont été tués à une
échelle horrible dit il on rapporte que
plus de 1000 morts au cours de la
première semaine de février seulement il
frappe sur les écoles les hôpitaux les
marchés se poursuivre
une mince consolation aujourd'hui dans
cet océan d'humanité oublier un convoi d
aide humanitaire est entré dans la
goutte à rians talent le premier depuis
la fin novembre
ça ne suffit pas vu la densité de la
population il docteur anas seules de
petites quantités dead sont arrivés un
peu plus de 7000 des quatre cent mille
personnes qui vivent dans ce chapelet de
villages aux portes de damas recevront
une partie de cette aide
assiégés depuis 2013 par les forces du
régime syrien
ils subissent pénurie de nourriture sur
pénurie de médicaments
sept ans après ses débuts parler d'un
simple conflit syrien ne suffit plus à
rendre compte de la réalité et ligne de
front se multiplient les alliances et
les antagonismes se métastase formant
une mosaïque complexe de joueurs
internationaux au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu les etats-unis et la russie se
sont tour à tour accusé d' envenimer le
conflit par leurs interventions
c'est la 92e fois que se tient une
réunion du genre nations unies pour
discuter d'un cessez le feu et d'une
voie vers la paix
ah bon pendant ce temps 13 millions de
syriens dont près de la moitié sont des
enfants ont un urgent besoin d' aide
humanitaire qui ne vient pas et on ne
compte plus les morts sous les décombres
ici marie-eve bédard radio canada béroud